Absolutely.
And that's why they try to make fun of women for spilling the tea.
And they just mock these things to make us feel stupid about it.
So that the pick me girls immediately are like,
I don't gossip.
I'm not one of those girls.
To give us another thing
to kind of tear us apart and divide us as women.
And we need to remember gossiping not about each other,
but about what's going on between our relationships.
And if some girls gonna try to steal your man,
honey, then he was gonna be taken one way or another.
He was never your man.
He was just a fucking asshole that was trying to take advantage of you.
Consider her doing you a favor.
That's how men act when one dude hurts the other dude.
You know, maybe they fight or have it out for a quick second,
but they're immediately like, bros before hoes.
But girls are the dummies that are like,
she took my man!
And getting all, like,
all emotional about it. Like, girl,
let it go. The line goes around the block.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, exactly.
Girls need to gossip,
spill the tea, and commune with each other.